so did something happen
yeah an unprecedented leak at the
supreme court sending democrats and
republicans into a frenzy but for
different reasons
chief justice john roberts confirming
the authenticity of a draft opinion that
would overturn roe versus wade while
pointing out that the supreme court has
not made a final decision
robert's ripping the leak as an
egregious breach of trust and is
ordering an investigation
president biden and democrats ignoring
the leak and are instead attacking
republicans and conservative justices on
the high court
if
this decision holds
it's really quite a radical decision
this is a dark and disturbing morning
for america this is a five alarm fire we
need to get rid of the filibuster and
roe is just exhibit a part of this
november's election reproductive rights
will be on the ballot this would appear
to be an invitation to have you know
handmaid's tale type
anti-feminist
regulation
these justices are acting like
this is somehow something that they have
the right to change they do not have the
right to change this wow this isn't
coordinated at all
democrats also telling their supporters
to get out there in protest
meanwhile republicans say the leak was
meant to intimidate the justices into
changing their vote
the radical left immediately rallied
around the toxic stunt making a
last-ditch
hail mary attempt
to cause a political firestorm
and cause the court
to reconsider democrats really don't see
the rule of law or the court's
independence as principles that are
above politics that's a real significant
breach of trust you want to talk about
an insurrection you know that's a
judicial ins
if only we had a judge here
all right judge
who do you think leak did and why and
give us your give us your assessment of
this whole scene i don't have the
slightest idea who leaked it but i'll
tell you this whoever leaked it did
something that is unheard of in american
history i mean you just don't leak a
decision by any judge let alone a
supreme court justice i mean there is
and one of the things that we can be
proud of is that the justices on the
supreme court they can be on the
opposite side of issues but you never
hear about them not getting along i mean
we hear about scalia ruth bader ginsburg
the best of friends although
ideologically they were on opposite
sides so whoever leaked this we have to
find out who the person is and and
charge them with a crime i don't know
what the crime would be whether it's
some kind of fraud on government
property i've heard there's a statute
fraud on a government that's very broad
that could include this kind of uh act
but i'll tell you what's so interesting
about this is if they wanted to to gin
up the left who was in for a alleged
bloodbath in november by the republicans
there is no better way to do it than
with roe versus wade but if you'll just
indulge me for a minute i read the
decision at length the dobbs decision as
well as roe again
roe they say in this decision is an
exercise of raw judicial power in other
words it is a supreme court acting as a
legislative body and understand that if
this decision is ultimately the decision
of the court it doesn't outlaw abortion
all it says is we're saying it's not a
constitutional right congress can pass a
law so if chuck schumer is so fired up
pass a law chuck every state can pass
its own law they can they can you know
negate it they can ban it they can they
can promote it whatever they want to do
but this is what i think is so stunning
about it
this decision says there is no right to
abortion that is implicit in the
constitution understand there are three
tests number one is it in the
constitution is it a constitutional
right freedom of speech is a
constitutional right first amendment the
right to bear arms is a constitutional
right second amendment but the right to
an abortion it is implied based upon
what rose says it's the first fourth
fifth ninth fourteenth amendment and i
won't get into it but they say we don't
know which one for sure but it's through
the due process clause in order for it
to be part of due process and legal and
constitutional it must be up deeply
rooted in our nation's history and
tradition
and it must be implicit in order
liberty
is abortion deeply rooted in our
nation's history
no in fact at the time of roe virtually
every state outlawed abortion and at the
right before row going back to the
common law it was murder uh and then it
was reduced to a misdemeanor in some
in some states and is it is is it
implicit in the concept of ordered
liberty no
even ruth bader ginsburg said that so
that is something that is based i think
very well
uh on very well argued and you know in
order for the left to get everyone fired
up they want someone on the right to
cave to the mob they want to intimidate
some justice on the right to back up and
support it but it's not a constitutional
right like same-sex marriage like uh
interracial marriage like contraceptive
loving versus virginia griswold versus
connecticut all those cases this
involves a third party
and that's the difference there you go
that was pretty clear
i feel like i could just i'm gonna just
say thank you for coming to her ted talk
i know exactly so
the judge brings up something very
interesting the timing of this
and we talked about this that things are
going so bad for the democrats that some
they need something and i mean this is
an amazing distraction before the
midterms now everyone's hair is on fire
instead of talking about or focusing on
inflation crime the border
so i have lots of different thoughts one
i think that the people who supported
roe v wade were living on borrowed time
and they knew it because this decision
as the judge just pointed out even ruth
bader ginsburg was like this is this
thing was poorly decided and so at some
point that was going to happen um
there's a lot of
claims today that this is the death of
democracy when actually what happens is
your state legislature
will decide to bring it up again and
some states like colorado have a very
very permissible abortion and then you
might have another state like of
mississippi that's going to go in a
different direction but the voters will
get to decide and that is what happens
in our republic that's how it works yeah
and roe v wade was anti-democratic
because supreme court is not a
democratic institution absolutely and so
when you have somebody like liz warren
saying well we absolutely must kill the
filibuster in order to pass this well
they couldn't pass it even in february
they got 46 votes for a bill that they
wanted to try to codify row it doesn't
work so you have for example aoc
attacking kirsten cinema today but they
don't even have the vote so the internal
democratic fighting will continue
i also think that there's you're going
to hear a lot about
that the justices when they were in
their confirmation process
would have private meetings with
senators and they would tell them what
they thought because they always are
asked do you think that roe v wade is
settled law and they'll say well they
told me it was settled law well now
you'll have some senators saying they
lied to me
and so the question is then why and i
maybe when the decision actually comes
out there will be a more fulsome
discussion of that as to why this
happened or maybe they'll do an
interview but remember separate but
equal was settled law until it wasn't as
well right so there was a case that was
brought before the courts it's gone
through the system and even the liberals
knew that mississippi state law when
it's when it got passed they thought oh
boy here we go and i think that both my
last point would be that both sides have
gotten exactly what they said is coming
for years for
however long how long has planned
parenthood been telling everybody that
if roe is overturned women are going to
die and be second-class citizens which
is why you have a lot of people actually
think that today and then on the right
they've been saying if you elect
republican
presidents and republican senators and
you nominate conservative judges then
you will get to overturn roe v wade so
now both sides are going to have to deal
with the fallout on it yeah you know
joey i think you know what scares me
about this decision it's obviously going
to target the truly marginalized and i
speak of pregnant men
what are your thoughts
i have a lot of thoughts but i know i
don't have a lot of time so uh there are
two issues here one is the leak which
stands in itself as a controversy the
other is what might happen with roe
versus wade and how abortion is handled
in this country i think the one thing
that i want to remind people is that
people sitting at home watching right
now aren't constitutional scholars
and we we accept that there's a
religious right and there's a very
liberal progressive left that are very
passionate about this issue but there's
a lot of people in the middle that have
an opinion on this issue every agnostic
person that's ever held their own child
in their hand probably has an opinion
about this issue every single mother
that's ever been in a place that she
felt like was between
rocking a hard place in the worst
circumstance has an opinion on this
issue and that's why the supreme court
looks at this issue as unsettled as the
law on the land and that's why it's
probably important that someone who's
even pro abortion but a
constitutionalist might say yeah roe
versus wade probably over over reached
and didn't allow
the people in this country to make this
decision because it may be the most
complex issue we ever decide as a nation
we're asking the question what is life
somewhere between conception and
consciousness that's a hard issue to
explain or to or to define and science
isn't there that's why supreme court
struggled with this and that's why so
many people struggle with roe versus way
just got last word to you
a lot of words um
i was shocked by this last night i
really did not expect nine o'clock that
suddenly this would be what was
happening obviously it's something that
liberals have warned of and that
conservatives have long wanted so i
guess it's not a complete surprise the
timing is strange i have seen feasible
arguments for why it was a liberal clerk
that leaked this and why it was a
conservative clerk who leaked this
because
if it was a conservative it might be
someone who wants to keep all the five
judges that are on the side of alito's
opinion in their box there and they
don't want to leave any room for
pushback probably on someone like
justice kavanaugh who i think out of
that group would be the most likely to
maybe side with roberts who it seems
like is not with the group of five and
is writing a separate concurrence so
leaking is bad it should not happen
there have been partial leaks before
actually the original roe decision i
thought that was fascinating was
partially leaked
but it's obviously a huge deal the
numbers speak for themselves 63 percent
of americans believe that abortion
should be legal in all or most cases
most cases is where we get into trouble
to joey's point and that people want to
have some sort of conversation about a
viability date right that i think we can
all agree at least at this table that
these
laws that have come into place in
conservative states like mississippi
where we're talking about six-week
abortion bans i was recently pregnant i
did not know that i was pregnant at the
six week mark
i wanted my baby i am thrilled to have
my daughter but that doesn't mean that i
should have my ability to make my own
health care decisions stripped away from
me because i happen to live in that
state
what elizabeth warren was talking about
and everyone can make fun of her about
her hysterical nature she's absolutely
correct this law will hurt poor women
this law will hurt women who do not have
access to good health care i'm an upper
middle class white woman i will be able
to get whatever health care i want for
the rest of my life that is not true of
women that are struggling people who are
working two jobs and also the majority
of women who get abortions guess what
they've already been mothers they're
people who are making family planning
decisions this is not about teenagers
running around and getting pregnant in a
car and just saying oh i don't care or
people who think that abortion is the
same as the morning after pill it is not
it is one of what the most carefully
considered decisions that a woman makes
and that's why this law was so important
it was about privacy that i should be
able to go into a room with my doctor
and make a decision to to try to
influence them to get an abortion that's
part of the problem
it is a nuanced thing that every
specific individual has to make for
themselves and that might be why states
should be able to decide as a culture in
a in a sovereign state how they're going
to handle it why should you be
someone who can't live in the state of
texas for instance because you want to
be able to make decisions about how to
control your own body and i'm so sick
also seeing on television people who
were screaming that i was infringing on
their rights because i asked them to
wear a mask
telling you telling me that i have to
have a baby that i don't necessarily
want or that i reverse that argument
with vaccines as well
so i would still argue that a shot in
your arm is a little bit different than
a commitment to a person for 18 years
and republicans also no support for the
social services that they want to do
they just say have a baby and deal with
it
i think the assumption that uh it
that the poor
you know helping the poor by giving them
more abortions seems pretty gross giving
them options yes of course that's what
we call it
up next the media inflaming divisions
and ramping up hysteria over the supreme
court's abortion leak hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else